herr wiese wir haben immer einen
besonderen fall der spielt sich in
nordrhein westfalen ab sie werden davon
gehört haben von der erst 13 jahre alten
jasmin die ist dort wahrscheinlich auch
nach diskussionen mit ihren eltern mit
ihren mitschülern mit ihren lehrern auf
dem schulhof sitzer in der kälte will
kein unterricht drinnen machen im
klassenzimmer weil sie sagt ich will
nicht neben ungeimpften sitzen was ist
ihre botschaft an jasmin die schülerin
sie haben es angesprochen in meinem
heimatbundesland nordrhein westfalen hat
eine große sorge vor ungeimpften
schülerinnen und schülern es besteht
keine impfpflicht letztendlich an den
schulen ich glaube dass wir an den
schulen in nordrhein westfalen ein sehr
enges test regime haben es wird montags
mittwochs und freitags getestet man kann
da sehr gut diejenigen infektionen auch
heraus bekommen um für sicherheit zu
sorgen aber noch mal es ist eine
entscheidung die die schülerin für sich
getroffen hat um weitere
vorsichtsmaßnahmen zu treffen das sind
natürlich bilder die keinen gefallen
können in der aktuellen situation aber
noch mal es wird weitestgehend dafür
gesorgt dass in klassenräumen
schulunterricht stattfinden kann und ich
sage auch ganz deutlich ich möchte nicht
wieder dass schulen sprechen decke
geschlossen werden ja aber also ehrlich
gesagt mich wird dieses foto und wird
diese geschichte auf also ich kann da
nicht mehr einfach nur drauf gucken kann
sagen es bleibt jasmin ja selbst
überlassen wie sie damit umgeht ob sie
ins klassenzimmer neben einem umkämpften
sich gerne setzen möchte oder nicht mich
wird es auf und ich nehme das seit
wochen auch wahr dass diese diskussion
eben in die klassenzimmer in die schulen
zu den allerjüngsten reingetragen wurde
dass man dort weil man in der familie
eben diese diskussion kennt frau schimke
dass man auch dort jetzt dazu kommt dass
grundschüler sagen 'hey ich möchte nicht
mehr neben dir sitzen du bist nicht
geimpft ich möchte das nicht sie haben
in dieser pandemie alles sie haben
diejenigen die wütend sind auf den start
auf die politik auf ihren geimpften
schwager wenn sie so wollen und sie
haben auch jene menschen die furchtbare
angst haben und diese angst überträgt
sich daneben auch auf kinder und
jugendliche und dieses bild halte ich
für unerträglich halte es für
unerträglich wenn kinder auf diese art
und weise durch angst und panikmache die
zum teil auch stattfindet leiden müssen
und deswegen also wir versuchen ist zu
haus von unseren kindern fernzuhalten so
weit es geht bei uns zu hause gibt es
kein corona ja und ansonsten bitte ich
wirklich auch je in dieser republik auch
eltern die verantwortung tragen das
ganze auch wirklich mit maß und mitte
verhältnismäßig auch zuhause zu
debattieren hätte ist solch ein fall das
ist natürlich ein einzelfall aber wie
gesagt ich nehme das schon in der breite
war auch bei meinen kindern dass das im
klassenzimmer so diskutiert wird dass da
derjenige deren tagesaktuellen test
positiv gehabt hat dass die eine woche
lang gemieden wird im klassenzimmer wenn
wir solche geschichten hören müssen wir
da nicht einen schritt zurücktreten
müssen sagen wir müssen uns noch mal
angucken wo wir gerade übertreiben ein
ganz ganz wichtiges stichwort in der
partie nochmal wir als fdp sind da auch
immer wieder kritisiert wurden von der
einen seite und von der anderen seite
verhältnismäßigkeit ist wichtig
sicherlich auch in den familien das
deutlich zu machen dass ein grund
stichwort verhältnismäßigkeit warum wir
die quarantänezeit jetzt so massiv
reduziert haben weil wir nicht wollen
dass kontaktpersonen oder auch die ihnen
die sich infiziert haben über lange zeit
ausgegrenzt bleiben warum wir wollten
dass schulen offen bleiben also da bin
ich absolut dabei ich will noch ein satz
wenn sie mir erlaubt mehr weise zu frau
schimke sagen weil sie ja vorhin gesagt
hat die fdp sei die partei die für eine
impfpflicht ist und da vielleicht die
debatte an heinz das ist mitnichten der
fall wir haben verschiedene meinungen
frau schimpft ich saß ganz deutlich die
cdu csu oder sind sie ja derzeit die
einzige fast gesagt keine impfpflicht da
sagt die führungsspitze wir sind
eigentlich alle dafür also dieses
anheizen dieses übertreiben ich habe es
vorhin bei markus söder gesagt in bezug
auf die korona maßnahmen weil es nicht
ärgert das führt dazu dass solche
schülerinnen schüler solche vor solchen
situationen stehen und deswegen
verhältnismäßigkeit ein bisschen ruhe in
der debatte und sachlich abwägen das
hilft viel mehr als alles andere
politische man in jede richtung da
können wir einmal ein strich drunter
ziehen